Are you Marty?
-Yeah.
-What brings you here?
I don't know.
Phyllis made me come.
My sister.
She must be very persuasive.
So, tell me about yourself.
I run a fabrics company.
So you're the boss, that feel good?
It feels...
Phyllis has always been the strong one.
You are a grown man
hiding behind a wall of curtains.
I think I can help you.
First thing I'm gonna do is
completely unethical.
I'm gonna give you a hug.
I'm a hugger.
There's no shame
in feeling pain, Marty.
You're the ruler of your own domain.
Work begins at 9 a.m., sharp.
Phyllis!
I'm trying to be ruler of my own domain.
This therapy is really working out, huh?
It is, it really is.
The goal of life is to live.
So we'll turn you into
the man you truly deserve to be.
This doctor is a little... unconventional.
He's a miracle worker.
What is he doing here?
Helping us, what do you think?
-So much fun.
-Is that allowed?
Well I did the work, didn't I?
He's changed my life.
He's changed me.
You clearly have a good eye.
-Me?
-You're the one with the good eye.
Eyes.  Two eyes.
The, the...appropriate quota of
ocular spheres.
-Why are we running?
-I don't know. Run!
You are growing, Marty!
Is he your psychiatrist?
Psychiatrist, business partner,
best friend.
How does all that work?
He just has no boundaries
and I don't trust him.
Cut her out of your life.
She's the only family I have.
Without trust, we have nothing.
I trust you completely.
-This is my decision.
-He's living in your head.
I... am going to take care...
of everything.
Feels good, doesn't it?
Yeah.